there are two types of stimuli that you
can do to a patient to get a response
one type is called a central stimuli and
the other one is a peripheral stimuli a
central stimuli is when pressure is
applied to the center of the body or its
core to create pain and this tests the
brain's response to that pressure slash
pain so there's a few ways you can do
this one way that's typically used first
is through the trapezius squeeze and you
use your index finger and your thumb and
squeeze about one and a half to two
inches of the trapezius muscle and as
you do this you will start out and
increase the intensity or pressure on
that muscle for up to 10 seconds and
then know how the patient responds if no
response is noted then you could move to
supraorbital pressure and this is found
around the eyes if you go to the eyebrow
and go to the inner part and you just
feel with your thumb you can feel a
notch and here you will gradually apply
pressure for up to 10 seconds to that
notch and note the patient's response
now it's important to know before you
use these pressure techniques to achieve
a response in your patient that your
patient doesn't have some type of injury
so for instance if your patient has some
facial fractures especially around the
eyes you would want to avoid using the
supra orbital pressure technique because
this could cause further damage now
another type of central stimuli that can
be used is called the sternal rub
however it's really not recommended to
use this anymore because it can cause
bruising in patients the next type is
called peripheral stimuli and this is
where pressure is applied to a
peripheral extremity for instance like
the fingernail bed and this creates pain
and this will actually help test the
spinal cord's response to pain